turn his head a Batman franchise you
have to be more than twice just because
he played it the most time it doesn't
get him the best you're crazy
Christian Bale brought way more depth to
Batman than anyone before no he showed
the how and the why how Bruce Wayne
became the Dark Knight that is a credit
to the writing not the performance do I
need to talk about the voice and I know
you still haven't given me much of a
case okay fine
Michael Keaton he brought this subtle
layer crazy
not just torment but completely bugged
out nuts but it was all below the
surface you're telling me when
Beetlejuice started yelling at the Joker
and smashing crap let's get nuts that
was subtle
guys listen part of the beauty of Batman
is that he's almost infinitely
interpretable Bruce Wayne and his
obsessive quest are so well developed
that even a simple shift in what aspects
get emphasized can yield a whole new
character there's merit to every
variation besides which you're both
wrong okay Kathy I know you've got your
weird hetero crush on George Clooney but
series 219 episodes across six
television shows including playing the
character at multiple ages and six video
games Kevin Conroy for the win Oh No
you can but that was even Anna and yeah